today on the Matt wall show Republicans
pass a bill intended to give parents the
right to know what's going on in their
child's School Democrats respond by
claiming that government accountability
and transparency is yes somehow fascist
in our daily cancellation a radio host
in Boston provoked the fake outrage
Machine by accidentally saying a word
that was once used as a racial slur 80
years ago all of that and more today on
the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
inflation has consequences as the FED
raises interest rates to combat
out-of-control government spending
long-term bonds have diminished in value
which is crippling the banks depositors
are holding their breath and investors
are bailing on Bank stocks
diversification has never been more
important the recent surge in gold
prices is directly tied to an extremely
volatile Market this is why gold has
historically been a great hedge against
the stock market and against inflation
the only company I trust to help you
diversify into gold is Birch gold group
I've bought gold for Birch gold because
I want a safety net for my family and
you can do the same by texting Walsh to
989-898 to get a free info kit on gold
today they'll help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into a tax
sheltered IRA and precious metals uh
physical precious metals with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews Birch gold
is the company that I trust to protect
my future and yours that's Walsh to
989898 today
the republican-controlled House of
Representatives today uh passed the
parental Bill of Rights act as house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy has explained the
bill has five uh basic pillars or
platforms uh quote the parents Bill of
Rights has five pillars to ensure
parents have the right to have a voice
in their kids education
the right to know what's being taught in
schools and to see reading material the
right to be heard the right to see
school budget and spending the right to
protect their child's privacy and the
right to be updated on any violent
activity at school so essentially the
bill would would codify into law at the
federal level your right as a parent to
know what's happening while your child
spends seven hours a day at school
because you know your child is not when
he goes to school disappearing into the
Bermuda Triangle uh at school at least
that's not how it's supposed to be there
shouldn't be any mystery about what he's
doing or where he went or what he's
being told and taught
there should be no secrecy public
schools are government buildings they're
funded by the taxpayers transparency
should be absolute and unequivocal
and it shouldn't be remotely
controversial
the actual text of legislation of course
goes into greater detail about what
exactly a parent has the right to know
so here's a quick overview directly from
the bill that just passed through the
House of Representatives but will almost
certainly not even get a vote in the
Senate
unless you're probably going to take
over in 2024. uh so parents right to
know a local educational agency
receiving funds under this part shall
ensure that each Elementary School and
secondary schools Serve by such agency
posts on a publicly accessible website
or of the school or if the school does
not operate a website widely
disseminates to the public a summary
notice of the right of parents to
information about their children's
education as required under this act
which shall be in an understandable
format for parents and include at a
minimum the right to review and make
copies of at no cost the curriculum of
their child's School the right to meet
with each teacher of their child not
less than twice during each school year
the right to review the budget including
all revenues and expenditures of their
child's School the right to a list of
books and other reading materials
available in the library of their
child's school and inspect such books or
other reading materials the right to
address the school board of the local
educational agency
so obviously
that's what the bill does whoever is
opposed to the bill is taking the
opposing position on all of those points
or at least some of them so to be
opposed to this bill is to say that
parents should not have the right to
review the curriculum and parents should
not have the right to know what books
their children are being assigned and
parents should not have the right to
meet with the teachers and address the
school board uh where their child Goes
to School parents should not have the
right to know what's going on at school
neither should they have the right to
speak to anyone at the school or to
anyone who runs the school
this is the position of those opposed to
this legislation but the bill covers
more ground than just that it also gives
parents the right to know if their child
is being bullied at school or if the
child has expressed Suicidal Thoughts at
school or if the child has been caught
with drugs
and also this quote parents have the
right to know if a School employee or
contractor acts to change a minor
child's gender markers pronouns or
preferred name or allows a child to
change the child's sex-based
accommodations including locker rooms or
bathrooms
again consider the inverse proposition
consider what the opponents are saying
parents do not have the right to know if
their child is suicidal or being bullied
or using drugs parents do not have the
right to know if their child is gender
dysphoric or has started identifying as
the opposite sex parents do not have the
right to even know what name their child
is using
they're saying the school employees
should have more information about a
child's Mental Health
than the parents have
this is the actual position of the
Democrats who took to the house floor
yesterday to stridently oppose this bill
using a range of tactics of course
starting as always with the trusty straw
man approach listen
stream Mega Republicans don't want the
Children of America to learn about
the Holocaust don't we want our children
to be kind
don't we want our children to know that
slavery was wrong as I fight against
slavery today that still exists
don't we want our children to understand
the basis of all of our history the
mosaicness of this nation and
African-American history don't we want
teachers to get the salaries that they
deserve
okay so this bill apparently would stop
schools from teaching about the
Holocaust and slavery and it would
somehow also prevent our children from
being kind
well um you know I read the entire
legislation and I didn't find the
language Banning mentions of the
Holocaust and slavery I certainly didn't
find the anti-kindness provision that's
because none of that exists nobody is
trying to stop schools from teaching
about either of those things those
things in fact when it comes to slavery
my personal View and the view of uh of
of many of the people that would be
labeled far right extremists by these
people
is that much more should be taught about
slavery not only do I not wish to
silence all mentions of slavery but in
fact I want a much more robust and
wide-ranging slavery curriculum I mean
it is an important fact about world
history emphasis on world world history
you know slavery is an important part of
that important part of that story
the problem with the way that slavery is
taught in school today is not that it is
taught or that too much is said on the
subject but rather that the lessons are
intentionally narrow so as to give the
laughably false impression that slavery
was a sin unique to white westerners
kids should be taught the truth that
slavery was you know a ubiquitous
institution across the entire Globe for
Millennia that Africans kidnapped and
sold each other into slavery that white
Europeans were captured and sold into
slavery themselves by Arab slave Traders
for centuries that Western Powers
abolished slavery and the slave trade
long before much of the rest of the
world did Etc all of this should be
taught
but leftists are the ones who don't want
any of that mentioned they are the ones
trying to censor the slavery
conversation in schools as usual they
are guilty of the sin that they are
accusing others of committing
many other Democrats Rose to speak up
against the Bill here's a squad
benchwarmer uh pramila jayapal
expressing her concerns about the bill
watch
we're spending time on a bill that sows
doubt about public education and our
teachers and also targets our very
vulnerable trans kids who are absolutely
no threat to anyone in this body
please understand that the provisions in
this bill that out trans kids are cruel
and dangerous I say that as a mom of a
trans kid and I was very embracing to my
daughter when she came out but not every
family is the reality is 75 percent of
trans kids experience discrimination and
harassment so why do Republicans want
schools to require outing lgbtq students
that does not make them better students
well of course she has a trans kid she
may not dress very well but a trans kid
is one fashion accessory that she
certainly does have she says that the
bill outs trans kids and Outing a trans
kid which is of course impossible to
begin with because trans kids don't
exist because no child is actually trans
but outing in this context means not
keeping a secret from the parents it
means that the parent
will know
what everyone in the school already
knows
okay jayapal believes that there should
be facts about a child extremely
important facts having to do with their
Mental Health
that a child's peers should know
all the friends know all the kids know
and all of the adults in the school know
but if the parents don't know
she wants to protect the rights of
government employees adults to conspire
with children to keep secrets from
parents
she wants the government and government
employees to know more about the child
than the child's parents do
um and this is especially Insidious when
you consider the as they are so quick to
always tell us about uh which is true
these sky-high rates of
suicide
and self-destructive Behavior among
trans identified people
okay being trans identified is a major
suicide risk among many other things
and you think that parents shouldn't
know that
their child is a is at a high risk of
suicidal thoughts and suicidal actions
and you think they shouldn't know
well this is the very essence of
Grooming
trying to adults
trying to keep secrets from parents
you know very essence of Grooming
this is what we mean we call them
groomers and speaking of groomers here's
AOC
they are asking the Republican party to
keep culture wars out of classrooms our
children need urgent and aggressive
educational Solutions the American
Library Association coming out against
this Republican proposal
when we talk about Progressive values I
can say what my Progressive value is and
that is freedom over fascism thank you
gentlemen's time is expired
now we already know that these mental
midgets will call anything they don't
like fascism they demand that we come up
with a you know they demand that we come
up with a precise definition of the word
woke while they drunkenly throw around
the term fascism with Reckless abandon
right everything is is fascist if you if
you step on their toe accidentally
you're a fast if you cut them off in
traffic during fascist every statement
they make is like it's like Mad Libs but
every blank is filled in with the word
fascist
but think about the specific context in
this case AOC is actually claiming that
it's fascism for private citizens to be
informed about what the government is
doing she is a politician accusing
citizens of fascism for demanding
transparency from government
institutions it is fascism for you as a
parent to be informed about what the
government is doing
and saying
to and with your child
the non-fascist or anti-fascist approach
by aoc's telling is for government
institutions to take ownership of your
child educate him in Secrets teach
whatever the state deems appropriate
without any input from parents and
taxpayers
that is what she wants you to believe
because she thinks you're stupid
or she wants you to be stupid
which not incidentally is also the goal
of the public school system and also why
yet another reason why we need a bill
like this
now let's get to our five headlines
using the internet without expressvpn
it's kind of like checking your baggage
at the airport without a lock you think
yourself is your stuff is safe but how
do you know for sure that no one is
going to go through your personal items
when you go online without a VPN
internet service providers isps you know
they can see every single website you
visit they can legally sell this
information without your consent to ad
companies and Tech Giants who then use
it to Target you when you use expressvpn
your identity is anonymized by a secure
VPN server so isps cannot see your
online activity your data is encrypted
for maximum protection as well I love
expressvpn because it's incredibly easy
to use I just fire up the app I click
one button I don't need to understand
how it works it just does and then my
phone my laptop even my Wi-Fi router all
are safe to keep my data private when I
go online I use expressvpn
if like me you believe that your data is
your business secure yourself today with
the number one rated VPN on the market
is expressvpn.com Walsh should get three
extra months free that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Welsh to
learn more
okay more action in Washington DC
yesterday this is from the hill it says
tick tock's Chief Operating Officer
blasted The house's hearing on the
platform Thursday saying that it came
from a place of xenophobia
so it was a hearing on Tick Tock and the
possibility of banning Tick Tock and
um surprising no one
Tick Tock has pulled out the xenophobia
uh uh accusation Vanessa Papas who's the
tick tock CEO wrote on Twitter we're
committed to providing a safe secure
platform that Fosters an inclusive place
for our amazing diverse communities to
call home it's a shame today's
conversation felt rooted in xenophobia
thank you to our employees who work
tirelessly to protect our platform and
community
oh yes poor Tick Tock that uh you know
multi-billion dollar social media
conglomerate is is now a victim of
xenophobia
uh Tick Tock CEO shoesy Chu testified on
Thursday in front of the house committee
on Energy and Commerce as a bipartisan
group of lawmakers grilled him on
concerns of censorship and National
Security regarding the platform
representatives of the social media
platform accused the hearing of being
dominated by political grandstanding in
a tweet on Thursday quote our CEO came
prepared to answer questions from
Congress but unfortunately the day was
dominated by political grandstanding
that failed to acknowledge real
solutions already underway through
project Texas or to address
industry-wide issues of Youth safety
also not mentioned today by members of
the House Commerce Committee the
livelihoods of the 5 million businesses
on Tick Tock or the First Amendment
implications of banning a platform loved
by 150 million Americans
the hearing comes after the by
Administration demanded the Chinese
owned parent company of tick tock sell
its shares or risk getting banned in the
United States China said on Thursday it
would resolutely oppose any forced sale
of the app
um
so I'm not even sure what the what the
general feeling about this hearing has
been uh in the public I haven't really
paid attention I read just a few reports
about the hearing and I saw some of the
clips and uh honestly I'm not impressed
with anyone involved in this thing
and and in fact uh some of what we heard
there from the the tick tock you know
people is a political grandstanding like
they're they're obviously not entirely
wrong about that the the xenophobia
stuff is ridiculous but
um yeah there was political Grand
there's a lot of political grandstanding
from the from the eclipse that I saw uh
I mean there were moments like this
watch this
do you agree that the Chinese government
has persecuted the uyghur population
well it's really concerning to hear
about all accounts of Human Rights abuse
my role here is to explain what your
platform does it's a pretty easy
question do you agree that the Chinese
government has persecuted the uyghur
population
congresswoman I'm here to discard but
Tick Tock and what we do as a platform
and as a platform we allow our users to
freely Express on this issue that
matters to them
well you didn't answer the question
all right um I mean yeah he can't really
answer that question because then uh if
when he goes back to China you know
we're never going to see him again
um and that's not really like that's not
relevance
at all to the question of whether or not
Tick Tock should be banned in the United
States
uh that has got nothing to do with it
and there were a lot of moments like
that politicians looking for their viral
moments and uh these hearings it's
always that it's like each politician is
taking their turn and they have their
little speech and they're looking for
their moment and uh there were a lot of
moments of um you know they would ask a
question and then the guy would start to
answer it is out no yes or no question
um
you know because they don't really want
an answer what they want is an
opportunity to speak themselves and so a
lot of stuff like that now don't get me
wrong I'm not defending Tick Tock I mean
yes ban Tick Tock okay ban it from the
planet uh shoot it into the Sun as far
as I'm concerned sounds good to me I'm
on board for that
I guess just call me cynical here I
don't believe
anything will actually happen
um I don't believe that
open proven wrong
I don't think I'm actually going to do
anything I don't think they're gonna ban
Tick Tock I think this is Justin that's
all it is an opportunity for this kind
of Showmanship
um and I've seen way too many of these
hearings where politicians take turns
Republicans in particular I mean
Democrats do it too but it annoys me
more with Republicans because you know
they're pretending that they're going to
do something I actually want them to do
and then they don't do it but I've seen
um too many of these hearings were
politicians take turns you know putting
their foot down and standing up for the
American people and you got these Great
Moments and they go viral look at what
he said and then nothing happens nothing
happens after that
and I get the same sense here uh but
hopefully I'm wrong
but there's another Point too
that much of the hearing was centered
around issues of National Security you
know uh issues of uh there were a lot of
questions about does tick tock you know
how much access does it have to a
personal information of its users how
much how much information is it is it
you know uh what what are the does it
keep a database of that information all
that kind of stuff and some of some of
tick tock's Defenders
in this country I've pointed out that
yeah well I mean Facebook does that
Twitter does that all these all these
platforms do that you know they're all
like spying on us and and saving our
information and selling our information
doing God knows what else with it and
that's true that's like every every
platform does that
um it's a greater issue with Tick Tock
because Tick Tock is also a spy app
really for the Chinese government and
that's the problem but
as far as I'm concerned that is not the
primary problem with Tick Tock I mean
the National Security concerns
are a major concern
but
for me that's not why I want to ban it I
want to ban it because the app is
terrible for kids
that's what I care about
okay even if they were able to
hypothetically like prove that this
isn't being used by the Chinese
government to spy on us and all that
stuff is above above board and
everything's fine there I mean they
could never prove that but
hypothetically if they did I would still
want to ban it
because that's not my main issue with it
my main issue again is is uh the effect
it has on kids
you know Tick Tock is uh
putting this the spying stuff aside Tick
Tock is a psyop
by the um
communist Chinese to make our kids
stupid and distracted
now we've talked before about I mean
Tick Tock in China is very different
from Tick Tock here
Tick Tock in China kids are exposed to
educational videos and stuff like that
um in this it here it's not like that
it's just nothing but stupidity and
filth and uh and you know loud noises
and uh and and all of bright lights to
distract them and just make kids Dumber
and uh more desperate for stimulation
um
Tick Tock is not like all social media
does that to kids and all social media
is bad for kids
but
Tick Tock is especially bad just the way
that it's set up
and uh and it's also you know one of the
most one of the most popular apps for
kids
so it's hurting our kids
you know it and that should be enough of
a reason
like there's this idea that we need more
of a reason than that we need to be able
to say more about like it's very bad for
kids
so I can say that
and then the response is well what else
though
and why else should we ban it what do
you mean why else why is that not enough
that should be enough
okay if there were actual uh
constitutional rights in play here or at
Jeopardy
then yeah it's not always good enough to
just say think of the kids you know
um but there isn't what what rights are
are on the line
you ban Tick Tock whose rights are you
infringing on
you're not infringing on the rights of
anyone who uses the the app there's no
constitutional right to use tick tock
and there are a million other social
media apps out there
so whose rights are being infringed on
but
this the Chinese company of tick tock is
that is that who we're infringing on
the Chinese uh whatever it is bike Dan
so the Chinese parent company we're
infringing on there right what right is
that
do they have do they have a
constitutional right to create this app
that's used in America by American kids
so no there are no rights at stake here
um
and so then it really becomes a pretty
simple
to me it's not very complicated it
becomes a really simple question
is this um hurting kids is it
detrimental to the well-being of
children uh yes is the answer and so yes
let's ban it
it won't hurt Society like what Tick
Tock is banned
in what way is society harmed by that
okay let's say we ban Tick Tock tomorrow
five years from now
what are the the negative consequences
of us not having tick tock
all right this is from the New York Post
it says a Houston teen has been accused
of slamming a mother of three into the
ground during a jugging robbery that
left the victim paralyzed and he
appeared this week in court where he had
his bonds slashed in half to a hundred
thousand dollars Joseph Harrell 17 was
ordered held last week on two hundred
thousand dollar Bond following the
heroin caught on camera February 13th
attack that left uh noong trong unable
to walk
she's the victim prosecutors had asked
for the 200 000 Bond because he had just
been released on a hundred dollars Bond
on J on January 26th on an unlawful
carrying of a weapon charge but his
court appointed attorney argued
Wednesday to have his bond reduced 100
000 saying his family could not afford
to Spring him
well good
how is that not the answer oh his family
can't afford to get him out good we
don't want him out
okay we yes yes keep him in the cage
his attorney Catherine Evans says it was
confirmed that Bond conditions are in
place that would Place Mr Harrell on
24-hour house arrest and require him to
wear a GPS monitor should family members
be able to post sufficient bonds at some
point in the future
um surveillance video shows Harrell had
uh trailed trong from a bank to a
shopping center for 24 miles
he then slammed her into the ground and
stole the 4 300 in cash he had just
withdrawn
um the prosecutors wrote while on bond
for all unlawful carrying a handgun
Harold stole money from from an
assaulted the victim causing the victim
broken ribs a fractured spine and
paralysis from below the arms which is
serious bodily injury
uh so she was paralyzed now and they're
now saying that um
she has a 50 chance of ever being able
to walk again
during the incident Harold and at least
one of the suspect allegedly stole a
woman's hold on a second
um I skipped ahead in addition to the
counts for aggravated robbery and
unlawful carrying of weapon Heralds
facing a charge of aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon stemming from
another incident on February 25th during
that incident Harold and at least one
other suspect allegedly stole a woman's
purse as she was leaving a business in
Southeast Houston the woman her husband
later tracked the suspects to a home
using air pods that were inside her
purse after recognizing uh Harold
outside the home woman called 9-1 while
they were waiting for police Harold
allegedly drove up to the couple and
asked if they needed something when they
replied they didn't he pointed a black
handgun at the woman who's being held on
a combined 130 000 bond for the
aggravated robbery on February 13th and
the aggravated assault with a deadly
weapon on February 25th
so we've got here what is that uh three
felonies
including uh violent assault and robbery
that left somebody paralyzed
and the response by the court system is
to
slash his bond in half
to make it easier for him to get back
out on the streets
you know this is
this is another one that that is not
complicated
um
you know it's it's not complex they're
not a lot of nuances to this
this is someone who should be thrown in
prison for the rest of his life
I mean at a minimum at a minimum
thrown in prison for our life you should
never see the outside of a prison
it does not benefit like what benefit
is there in in letting him
ever walk outside of a prison cell ever
again
and like we're always talking about any
any discussion of Criminal Justice
Reform because I do believe in Criminal
Justice Reform I I also think the
Criminal Justice Reform is desperately
needed in this country
the entire criminal justice system is
right now hopelessly broken
and needs to be uh reformed
but the reforms need to go the opposite
direction from what everyone is talking
about
and everyone that includes Republicans
uh that includes the Trump
Administration
and a Criminal Justice Reform you know
that was pushed and uh when Kim
Kardashian was being invited to the
White House to talk about Criminal
Justice Reform
so this is something that everyone gets
wrong Republicans and Democrats
Criminal Justice Reform should be
putting more people in prison
for longer that's the kind of Reform
that we need
we need a lot more people in prison and
that means we've got to build more build
more prisons
fill them and keep the people there for
much longer and lots of them keep them
there forever
and then there should be another portion
of people who we are letting out of
prison but they are getting out of
prison because they're going to be
buried in the ground because we're going
to kill them we're going to execute them
so that's the kind of Reform we need
we need we need we need reform that puts
a lot many more criminals in prison and
many more criminals in the ground
foreign
because that's Justice and if you
actually care if you have any compassion
in your heart whatsoever that is what
you would be calling for
as I said it's very it's really pretty
simple
it's a simple question of you know in
this case we have uh Harrell
the criminal with Joseph Harrell
and then we have the victim who's
paralyzed who matters more
who should we be more concerned about
as a society who should we be more uh
desperate to
help and protect
the violent criminal Joseph Harrell
who just keeps on committing crimes
because he hasn't you know it was as
long as he's out free he's going to be
committing Christ so is it him or is it
the the victim who's now paralyzed
who do you have more compassion for
who do you sympathize more with
should be a simple answer
all right
next we have uh this from Fox News
Health Providers at U.S military bases
some of whom are involved in treating
military-connected minors
blasted the idea of waiting before
injecting kids diagnosed with gender
dysphoria with puberty blockers and
hormones the dod providers said in a
March edition of the American Journal
Public Health that the only pathway for
children and Military members who
present their gender dysphoria symptoms
is to immediately move towards gender
affirming Health Care such as puberty
suppression and affirming hormones
the doctor said on the basis of Human
Rights
youths have an inherent ability and
right to consent to gender affirming
therapy they went so far as to claim
that seven-year-olds can make their own
medical decisions seven-year-olds
the authors David a Klein Thomas Baxter
Noel s Larson as well as clinical
psychologist Natasha chevay demanded the
military train all of its providers on
their ideas on gender medical
interventions for minors despite
acknowledging that 53 percent of the
military
of military-affiliated Physicians
Department of Health Department of
Defense Health System indicated that
they would refuse to prescribe hormones
regardless of any training
so now they're talking about
these kinds of quote unquote
medical interventions
for seven-year-olds
which is uh
you know
totally unfathomable to any
sane person maybe really you don't have
to be a parent you're just the same
person in general
but if you're a parent
who who has a seven-year-old or has had
kids that were seven
the idea that these kids have any like
uh
have any concept at all about what's
good for them what's right for them
it is uh it is
just unfathomable it truly is
and indefensible
but it's all part of the part of the
agenda we can't act like we're surprised
where this is heading
you know they are saying these are the
Department of Defense and these doctors
so-called doctors are saying that
seven-year-olds have the mental capacity
the psychological uh capacity and mental
formation
to consent to life-altering
life-changing
um medical decisions
okay so this is their notion of consent
that they are applying to very young
children
so when when you know this this slippery
slope only heads in One Direction and we
can't be surprised when it gets there
speaking of which I want you to listen
to this video uh this went viral a few
days ago it's a video of a girl
explaining her um complicated
gender Dynamics listen
I think that's complicated about my
whole like gender situation and I feel
like there are other non-binary people
who do what this do is the fact that the
way I understand my gender and the way
that I want other people to understand
my gender are two wildly different
things because I and certain people that
I've talked to about this understand the
nuances and complicated relationships
that I have with Womanhood so those are
included when we think of me as a woman
or say she her like those weird
relationships are still understood but
almost everyone else they don't have
that so they don't get to call me those
things to almost everyone else in real
life I am not a woman and I use they
them but then because I will call myself
a woman or use she her understanding the
nuances of it all I feel guilty when I
feel bad about getting misgendered by
people who should be using they them and
not thinking of me as a woman I mean
they're not wrong except they don't know
they're not wrong they've been told I'm
non-binary and I use they them so why
are they still thinking of me as a woman
you know um
on top of everything you just heard
there being totally wrong and deranged
um obviously
the other big concern for me with all
this stuff
and anytime I see one of these uh one of
these Tick Tock videos
it's just that it's it's such a useless
thing
to be thinking about
okay that you have these young people
millions of young people who are utterly
obsessed with this useless nonsense
and so just think about all of the
mental real estate that's being occupied
by this kind of thing when they're just
sitting around constantly pondering
um the mysteries of their own gender
identity
and I'm uh I'm this gender in this
context but I want people to see me this
way and I want to be perceived this way
but but I feel this way
all of it is is on top of being wrong
it's just completely useless
this is what you're spending your time
thinking about
and I I can't help but think about all
of the
um
Innovations and uh inventions and um
artistic
ideas and medical cures that we aren't
getting
because the people who might have
thought of them were instead busy
thinking about this
that goes back to that's why I want Tick
Tock band is is because of that
especially when you're young it's like
the the the the the the age range that
is particularly susceptible to this kind
of stuff
um
this is also the age when people are
supposed you're supposed to be the most
energetic and creative and uh and uh you
know and in Innovative and all of that
but instead they're just totally lost in
kind of the the Maze of their own
self-obsessions and they can't think
about anything else because they can't
they can't look forward at the rest of
the world
they're not looking out at the world
they're just looking back within
themselves all the time
and not finding any clarity about who
they are but becoming perpetually more
confused
another good example here's someone who
identifies as a as a hawk apparently
my name is Horus and I'm a red-tailed
hawk in our world I do have the body of
a hawk but while fronting I consider
myself a Therian because I am in a human
body but my identity is still a hawk not
all animal altars will identify this way
and I am in fact the only animal alter
in our system who does identify this way
I am doing my best to come to terms with
living in a human body
um
so this is someone who is uh pretending
to be trans species and also pretending
to have multiple personality disorder
which we've talked about before on the
show uh that thanks to tick tock uh that
is also a big Trend these days you know
it's very trendy to have mental
illnesses in general and you got all
these kids that are like constantly
coming up with new mental illnesses that
they have
and they all want to have at least a
couple mental illnesses they take a lot
of pride in being mentally ill and they
invent me you know and so so one of the
trendiest mental illnesses on Tick Tock
right now is uh multiple personality
disorder which doesn't even exist okay
it doesn't exist it's been it was made
up it's like it's this entirely
fictionalized made up
uh that from the very beginning it's
like you get another thing we can thank
uh psychiatrists for it's like coming up
with this concept of someone multiple
personalities trapped in their head
because they're trying to sublimate uh
you know traumas and they create so it's
just a literally like movie plot lines
that have been invented by the
psychiatric industry
um
and and multiple personality disorder
was very trendy for for a number of
years and then it kind of fell out of
fashion
and that tells you something by the way
that that certain mental illnesses have
a have fashionable periods
you know mental illness has become like
uh it's like uh like genes you know
there are certain Gene styles of genes
that are trendy in certain you know
certain decades and you can almost like
Define a decade by the kind of genes
people wore
um
and it's like that now with mental
illnesses
so
she's uh pretending to be another
species and also pretending to have have
multiple personalities and I I guess
from this I'm getting that she so she
has Alters that's what they call uh
their their other personalities and I
guess all of her other personalities are
animals I don't know if they're all
hawks or she's got other I'm not sure
she's got like a whole zoo inside her
head uh she's got all these different
animals
now here's what I want you to understand
though when you see videos like that and
I think people oftentimes get oftentimes
will get this wrong
and I saw that video being shared
on Twitter and and
the reaction for most people especially
on the right is uh well you know we got
a serious mental illness problem in this
country this is mental illness and these
are people that need you know severe
therapy and maybe need to be
institutionalized and um my point is
that that that
actually no this is not even a
legitimate mental illness okay so you
have to understand this is not someone a
girl you just saw there she is not
actually psychotic she's not like what
is that what we think we think that
mysteriously every we've got millions of
people all all good have gone psychotic
and they all have these like what are
they were they all born with the mental
illnesses how does that work
no it's a it's a game it's like it is a
it's a trend it's a game it's a
performance it is a performance that all
of these kids are engaging in
um
that's what it is
but then Society takes it seriously
and then they take it seriously
and after a while they start to forget
that it is a performance
so it's a performance that even they
after a while take seriously and that's
almost all this stuff
the mental illnesses they're inventing
for themselves the the uh you know the
split personalities the uh the the
different genders the non-binary this
and that it's like it's performance
um
but it becomes its performance
that becomes a lifestyle
because Society rather than saying okay
stop being ridiculous okay this is what
society's response to someone like that
it shouldn't be oh let's sit down and
talk about this let's no it's like stick
cut cut but like be serious okay that
you're not a hawk all right
stop it
that should be a society's response to
that just stop it all right shut up like
go go get a job
in in a in in a more healthy era that's
how Society responds to that
but instead we take it seriously and uh
and then they take it seriously and then
what should be just kind of a trend and
a and a a fad and a phase uh becomes a
lifestyle
and then after a while
that's that's when maybe it actually
becomes an actual mental illness it's
almost like a mental illness that
they've tricked themselves into
and that we have as a society helped to
uh
form for them
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
you know if you have a family like I do
you already have plenty of things to
worry about in a worst case scenario you
wouldn't want them to worry about money
now we all hope that we'll never need
life insurance but mortgage payments
child care and other expenses they don't
disappear when you're gone a good life
insurance plan can give you peace of
mind that if something happens to you
your family will have a safety net so
they can get back on their feet and
focus on what's most important Posse
genius makes it easy to compare life
insurance quotes from top of companies
and find your lowest price if you
already have coverage through worker
employer-sponsored life insurance uh it
may not offer enough protection for your
family's needs and it won't follow you
if you leave your job so policy genius
is here for the policy genius you can
find life insurance policies that start
at just 25 dollars per month for a
million dollars of coverage some options
offer coverage in as little as a week
and they avoid unnecessary medical exams
there are no added fees and your
personal info is private your loved ones
deserve a financial safety net you
deserve a smarter way to find and buy it
head to policygenius.com and click the
link in the description to get your free
life insurance quotes and see how much
you could save that's policygenius.com
today
Janet says you would decry anything Anna
kasparian says because she's a woman and
your small brain and inflated male ego
dictate that a woman can never be
smarter than a man as for Giselle
American athletes are notorious for
their philandering how do you know this
was not her reason for the divorce oh
but wait in your Christian view a
woman's duty is to stand by her man no
matter how he fails as a husband right
my only question to you Janet is you
watch the show you watch this show I
mean you watch the entire show because
you you talk about something from the
beginning and the end
uh I mean I'm glad you watch
thanks for watching
but how how do you get through a show
like is this the first one you ever
watched
if this is the if it was the first show
you ever watched why why'd you watch the
whole thing
again I'm glad that you do like you need
to be exposed to some common sense in
your life
but it's just it's always amazing to me
when I read uh comments like this from
someone it's like if this is your
mentality if you're the kind of person
who uh would you know use a phrase like
inflated male ego
uh and assume the kind of person who
would assume that any criticism of a
woman is automatically sexist if you're
that kind of person
how can you even make it through an
entire episode of of my podcast
uh but again I'm glad that you're here
and uh
I tell you Janet what you need in your
life is a mansplaining uh you've you've
not had enough mansplaining in your life
and now you're going to get some so I'm
glad you're here thanks for watching
um
Lindsay says I want a whole hour of sdw
talking about the greatness of space
well I wish that
your opinion was shared by everyone but
there are also a lot of comments like
this from Sarah says oh my God people
stop bringing up aliens to Matt it's
just like with my grandpa there are
certain subjects you just don't bring up
otherwise you'll be stuck there for five
hours sitting on uncomfortable plastic
covered brown couches staring at the
shag carpet and rethinking all your life
choices while he drones on and on and on
you know I I don't you don't I assume
you didn't mean that as a compliment
Sarah but I sort of take it that way so
the experience we should put that in the
tagline like we need to send that over
to marketing the experience of watching
the Matt wall show it is much like
listening to your grandfather drone on
and on while you sit on uncomfortable
Furniture
um in a
in a
with in a living room with shag carpet
like that's that's what listening to
Matt wall show is like
and I'm okay with that as I said I take
that
as the highest of compliments
um
sweet baby Soca says Matt maybe God made
this vast universe so that we could be
humbled at how small we are and not get
too cocky
um yeah I mean sure
I I think that that's part of the effect
of living in a vast universe
and I wouldn't be and I am sure in some
ways part of
the intention behind it but I I also
just think um
like that's really so the entire
universe everything in the universe
including all the galaxies that we can't
even like see you know all of that is is
only there just to Humble us it's just
to like keep us better adjusted and keep
our our head on our shoulders straight
um
I can't help but see that as as a as a
rather egotistical view of the universe
that's the only reason it's all there
um
maybe it's also their
because there are there's there's other
life that's being harbored I don't you
know
that doesn't that's not that's not a
view that uh challenges my faith at all
that's one thing I'm getting from this
conversation of course is that for a lot
of people they feel that it challenges
and I think that's really what this is
about I mean it's clearly what it's
about for a lot of people that they just
think that they can't entertain the
notion that there might be other life in
the universe because it would challenge
their faith and uh and so it's like
there's no argument that will get
through to them because they just they
feel like they can't believe that they
can't accept it they can't
I I don't have that hang up and I I
still don't understand people have tried
to explain it to me I just don't get it
like I I really don't I don't understand
how the existence of other life in the
universe would somehow challenge
the notion of God why would it that in
fact there's another comment yesterday
that I didn't get to but someone said
that um
you know if you believe another life in
the universe then it's because you don't
believe in creation
you know it's uh you don't believe in CR
what do you mean so if you believe in
other life it means that you don't think
God created the universe why that's not
what I think
no it's just God created that life too
why is that why is that challenging I
don't I just don't get it
um all right
and
there's one other here Ranger one says
Matt Matt seems to begin by seeking the
most universal and beneficial principles
possible such as truth Clarity the
sanctity of Life Etc and then he builds
vast complex ideas upon the foundations
of those principles he can discuss any
idea openly and doesn't contradict
himself in any meaningful way because
all of his ideas emerge naturally from
the same Foundation his opponents appear
to begin by noticing some personal
desires exist and construct whatever
principles are necessary to justify
pursuing it pursuing interest based upon
moral principles that exist only as long
as the personal interest that they serve
exists is a path to narcissism suffering
or Madness knowing this anyone who
argues with them becomes an enemy to be
destroyed
well that's very insightful
and that also you know is a good uh a
good way of describing the show although
I sort of prefer
that I'm just someone's grandfather
rambling while they listen slightly
annoyed
either way I think works
and I'll never understand virtue
signaling making yourself look important
with the least amount of effort is like
the reputation of equivalent of Stolen
Vowel Valor and reputation is just one
of the things that Jordan Peterson
discusses with his Roundtable group of
Scholars and theologians in the latest
episode of Exodus check it out I do I
don't think when we've talked in our
culture a lot about virtue signaling
it's not exactly a great phrase because
really what you're trying to do when you
virtue signal is you're trying to
acquire a reputation that you haven't
earned and the reason that people are so
motivated to do that is because once you
can abstract an ethic there's actually
nothing that's more valuable than your
reputation right it's the thing upon
which all the trades that you uh engage
in with everyone else depends right
you're as good as your reputation and so
if you can get that falsely it's a real
crime and if you can Savage it without
cause it's an equally egregious crime
do it so often and so narcissists and
I'm sure that's much worse so Jordan to
to have an an ill-gotten reputation
that's bad but to take away someone's
actually earned reputation I know that
there are no certain sense too it's a
battle between two Devils two sizes
well new episodes are coming online
every week exclusively for daily wire
Plus members you can join now at
dailywire.com subscribe to watch Exodus
now let's get to our daily cancellation
bye-bye
one of the perhaps most unexpected
aspects of wokism is that it's
constantly teaching us new racial slurs
that we never knew existed and our
racial slur vocabulary increased yet
again this week when the woke police
became outraged at Chris Curtis for
calling Mina kimes a nip quote unquote
now this immediately raises some
questions like who is Chris Curtis and
who is Mina kimes and what the hell is a
nip
I have no idea who any of these people
are or what the word is supposed to mean
and I suspect that most of the people
outraged or pretending to be outraged
were similarly Clueless
but just because they had no idea what
was going on or what was said or who
said it or who they said it to or about
or why that would not stop them from
being deeply traumatized by the
situation whatever the situation is
exactly so let's try to sort through
this earlier this week
a Sports Talk radio host on WEEI in
Boston jokingly called Mina kimes who is
apparently an ESPN sports analyst
um he said that she's one of his
favorite nips
now the joke was made in the context of
a conversation about little miniature
bottles of liquor which are also
apparently referred to as nibs I didn't
know that either
um here's that moment
begs the question top five nips uh oh
yes that's a great one uh because I
think is number one or two ball also up
there it's probably gonna and Fireball
Fireball
like I'm not taking it you're right
about the McGillicuddy though but do you
like the purple or the root beer
now Curtis has since clarified that um
he meant to make the joke about actress
Mila Kunis but he said Mina kimes and he
also said that his comment was
um sophomoric and sexist which clearly
indicates that his intention was to make
a boob joke okay it was a nips pun That
was supposed to be a reference to
breasts
and even without this clarification that
that already seems pretty obvious from
the context
but unluckily for Curtis it turns out
that nip
is also an obscure slur for Japanese
people last used you know sometime
around World War II
I have never in my life even one single
time ever heard that term used in
reference to Japanese people most of us
have never heard it
oh and by the way uh Mina kimes isn't
even Japanese she's Korean so so we're
left with two possibilities here okay
two possibilities
either
this radio host intentionally decided to
commit career suicide by knowingly using
it in archaic anti-japanese slur last
uttered in 1945 during the Battle of Iwo
Jima in reference to a Korean sports
reporter or
he was just trying to make a dumb boob
joke
those are the two potential explanations
here
and it's quite obvious which one is the
most plausible but in these sorts of
situations the most plausible
explanation is rarely the most useful to
the victimhood narrative so the outrage
mob got to work pretending to believe
that this was an attack on Asian people
pretending to even know that the word
was a slur to begin with pretending to
be offended pretending to have been
somehow deeply injured by an
off-the-cuff remark made by a radio host
that no one's ever heard of about
another media personality no one's ever
heard of there were calls for Curtis to
be fired there were condemnations being
issued denouncements ESPN spoke out
other sports media personalities chimed
in the whole circus of offendedness
commenced
the next day as expected Curtis issued a
groveling apology begging forgiveness
from those who were hurt
and he was then set off to sit in time
out and think about what he'd done this
of course is not enough for the
self-motoring idiots who are pretending
to care about this as this local media
report shows they still intend to milk
this for whatever it's worth watch well
the Boston sports radio host is off the
job tonight after using a racial slur to
describe an Asian-American ESPN reporter
weei's Chris Curtis says he's been
suspended for a week wbz's Laura hafely
shows us his apology and what made his
comment so hurtful
I just want to pause there for a moment
because uh because I I mean like I don't
mean to spoil this but I can tell you
what made his comment so hurtful and
that is um nothing
makes them hurtful because nobody was
hurt by them see there are two
categories of people when it comes to
situations like this in the first
category there are normal well-adjusted
human beings with lives to live and more
important things to think about and
worry about and those of us in that
category we don't have the time or
energy or inclination to be offended or
hurt by some dumb off-handed joke made
by some guy on some radio station
somewhere
in the other category are desperate
maladjusted pathetic ridiculous losers
who have nothing interesting going on in
their lives and have achieved nothing
and will never achieve anything and who
live for the opportunity to play the
victim waiting for someone to trip up
and you know say the wrong thing so they
can swarm and feast like piranhas
devouring a wounded goat wading across a
river but the people in that category
they're not hurt either quite the
opposite they're excited they're
thrilled they're like ravenous with
Hunger ready to devour their next victim
they're incredibly grateful that they've
been given another fake grievance
so nobody is hurt not one person on the
planet is hurt that is who is Hurt No
One not one person anywhere
okay let's continue
a ban on miniature liquor bottles was
proposed Monday by Boston City councilor
Ricardo Arroyo garnering attention from
Neighbors and local media Outlets
including the Greg Hill radio show on
WEEI the show's hosts were discussing
the ban using the nickname for the
airplane-sized bottles when producer
Chris Curtis appeared to referred to an
Asian-American ESPN journalist Mina
kimes in a racist manner it dragged her
into a controversy
through no fault of her own uh regarding
a slur and her race Curtis was suspended
by WEEI I want to apologize for the
stupid lame attempt at a joke is it ever
clever to to be Club you know to be
clever at the expense of somebody's
identity Professor David Howell teaches
Japanese history at Harvard so it's
really very much a term that was used
during World War II to refer to the
Japanese when they were the enemy it's a
classroom or
um on the air
using a term
almost you know makes it sound like it's
okay to use the term WBZ reached out to
the chair of the Massachusetts aapi
commission Dr Gary Chu let's not go back
to the past and perpetuate hate
especially aapi hate which has been on
the rise not only in the U.S but also in
Massachusetts in the city of Boston Dr
Chu hoping for accountability from the
radio host and more representation
moving forward anytime we can denounce
things like that uh we'll help we're
working to see to talk about all these
issues providing resources to elevate
the messages of what is going on so that
everyone understands the diversity of
the Asian American popular Asian
American and Pacific Islander
populations we did reach out to ESPN who
called the comments hateful and
extremely offensive we also reached out
to Odyssey the owner of WEEI they did
not immediately give back to us in
Brighton Laura hafley WBZ News
it's not really the point but uh just
just one note is that banning the small
bottles of liquor is a really stupid
idea to begin with uh because if you do
that
doesn't just mean people will buy bigger
bottles of liquor like what do you think
I I get the ideas because people buy
those little bottles it's like if if
you're if you're buying a little bottle
of liquor you're either an alcoholic a
college student not that those two
things are mutually exclusive or you're
on an airplane
um so it's really it's really uh it it
also actually by the way that that also
applies to if you're if you're buying
any kind of liquor at all or you're
consuming any kind of liquor at all
before like four o'clock in the
afternoon again you're either a college
student an alcoholic or you're on an
airplane but anyway you bet you ban the
small ones and so is that going to make
all the alcoholics say well guess I'm
not drinking any more liquor no now they
just buy bigger bottles and drink those
anyway so
but that's another
this is why you never apologize to these
people you never apologize to them
because this is who you are apologizing
to this is who the people you saw in the
video this is who you're bending the
knee to
these are the people whose feet you are
kissing these two guys that you just saw
right there it's always these guys
and people just like them okay they are
representative of who you are groveling
to you've got an insufferable college
professor in an ugly shirt with a smarmy
grin on his face looking down his nose
at you and telling you which words
you're allowed to use and which you
aren't allowed to use
it's not okay to say that well we don't
want people to have the impression that
it's okay to say that word it's not okay
to say that word because I say so
and then the other dude some useless
empty-headed bureaucrat with a doctorate
in self-victimization on some pointless
commission that does nothing at all
whose own entire purpose is to justify
its existence by looking for things to
complain about this this is entirely
perfunctory right for both of them their
hearts aren't even in it you can tell
especially the last guy there
you know that guy it's like he he
couldn't even he couldn't even pretend
to actually think that this matters okay
and he's well we need uh diversity we
need to raise awareness of diversity and
so people will know about diverse uh
diversity
they don't believe what they're saying
they don't care they're just Petty
tyrants looking for an opportunity to
impose themselves on other people
this goes for the two guys in the clip
and everybody else in the outrage mob
because that's the thing about the
outrage mob there isn't much actual
outrage to be found in it
it's all for show
which is why as I've been shouting for
years
and as I myself have lived by this is
not something I'm telling other people
to do that I won't do but you must never
apologize to them no matter what
you must never apologize to them
say whatever you want to these people
just never say you're sorry
but Chris Curtis did Apologize so I
cannot save him even if I wanted to
instead I could only say that everybody
involved in this situation is today
canceled and I'll do it for this portion
of shows and move over to the members
block you become you can become a member
today by using Code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]